(upbeat music)
- Hey everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is episode 310
of the Ask Gary Vee Show,
and literally, before Jesse
and I just went on air,
well, we're live, so you guys heard it,
but before this podcast we're literally
talking about the steroids
era baseball hearings
in congress which, I'm actually going
to go consume that
content, which I rarely do.
- [Jesse] It's well done.
- Why don't you tell the Vayner-nation
who you are and what you do.
- I'm Jesse Genet and I
run a company called Lumi,
and we do packaging for e-commerce brands,
helping e-commerce brands design their own
boxing experience and source and manage
all the stuff they need to
get it shipped out the door.
- And obviously if you're watching this
and not listening to it you see a huge,
the outer packaging of Empathy,
we're going to do an unboxing on IGTV
after this show, we are such proud users
of your wonderful
company at Empathy Wines,
empathywines.com, order now.
And have really enjoyed that experience
and just from a visual
has been remarkable.
Let's take a step back.
How did you get into this business?
- Well I started my first business
when I was 16 and have been...
Went to school for international design
later on, so I've always
basically been into
how products--
- So you were
an entrepreneurial kid--
- Yep, yep.
- And then your formal education was in
industrial design--
- My formal education
is stilted as a process,
I went to three years
of high school, did end
up going to college,
my parents were stoked about that
until I dropped out of that
experience as well, but--
- Did go to college--
- Did go to college.
- 'Cause they wanted you to.
- They were like, "This
seems important to you,"
I'm from the mid-west,
it was kind of like,
you should do that.
- It was too rogue, right?
- [Jesse] It was too rogue,
so I did go to college--
- Do you believe that your parents today
would have a different perspective?
- Um, not really.
- [Gary] Do you think you will?
- I definitely do, I--
- So real quick, and I
apologize for interrupting,
but this is my number
one thesis right now,
I know this is something
you're not supposed
to ask a lady, but this
is important to me.
- [Jesse] I can handle it.
- How old are you?
- [Jesse] I'm 31.
- Perfect.
You do believe that, as a
31 year old right now...
You don't have a family,
you don't have kids?
- [Jesse] Yeah, correct.
- You do believe right
now as you sit here today
that when the time comes,
let's just play here
for fun, in 27 years,
that you're not going
to be passionate for your
kids to go to college?
- I don't think I'm going to care
whether they graduate from college.
I think that the actual experience
of going to wherever you want to go,
to get the education you want to get,
is really important, and
sometimes that's going
to be at college,
sometimes it's going to be
other places, but the
concept that you need
a piece of paper at the end
to say I'm a valid person
to get this next job or
this next experience,
I don't think that that's
going to be a thing.
- It's funny, the reason I'm asking is
I genuinely believe you,
and definitely I believe
let's say the 21 year old
you, I think were just...
The reason people still go--
- I'm on the cusp,
my era's on the cusp--
- Correct.
- There's people younger who are like
definitely not going to do
it, they're doing Lammas
school and all this other stuff, right,
but there's--
- I mean, as parents.
- [Jesse] Yeah yeah.
- So I think college is held
up by parent's ideology.
- [Jesse] Oh, yeah yeah.
- So it's going to take...
I'm really curious and I genuinely believe
we're probably 30 years away
from it really collapsing,
because the parents won't force.
I think parents will send their kids...
By the way, this is going to throw a lot
of people off, I'm pumped
to send my kids to college.
I just don't think it's required.
I could watch them and
reverse engineer them
with my advice and let
them do their thing,
that's where I'm at,
that's for the framework.
- I think we're in a shifting mindset
on that now, I think
parents who have little kids
right now are not going to be as pushy
about going to college
because they're also
going to understand
the financial equation.
If you're a parent and
you have a little kid
right now and you recognize
you've got 15 years
about digging yourself
out of student debt,
you're not about to
push your kid right off
that cliff, basically.
- Couldn't agree more,
couldn't agree more,
and I remind people...
I had this woman the
other day yelling at me,
literally in the street
about fuck you about college,
and I looked at her and
I was like so pumped,
'cause she's going off and I'm like okay,
this is going to be epic.
Why the fuck is nobody filming me?
I was so pissed.
And I looked at her and I said,
you do know that people used to think
that a woman's place was at home
raising the family, right?
- How did that go?
This was on the street?
- And this was on the street,
and her face dropped--
- I also wish someone was filming.
- And I said, and she goes, what the hell
does that have to do with anything?
And I said, it has to do with ideology.
You can't rationally
tell me why every person
should go to college, you emotionally view
the world that way.
In 1964 an enormous
amount of men in America,
aka all of them, thought a
woman should stay at home.
I'm like, things that we
put on a pedestal change.
- They crumble quickly, and it's all about
what you actually need
to do what you're trying
to do next, right?
I think that that's a question we often...
We get in these tracks in
life and we think like...
It's like grades, when
you're like a little kid
you're trying to get your next grade
and get the gold star, and I think that
some of that behavior
is so ingrained in us
that it seems important.
- Correct.
- Like I started...
And also like that mentality of you start
something you ought to finish it, right?
Well, when does that break down?
When does that stop serving you?
- I couldn't agree more, and you also know
fast testing and it doesn't work, move on.
Everything's a
contradiction, imagine being
somebody in 1954 in America as a kid
looking at your parents and saying,
"I'm not going to church on Sunday,"
because most of the country did.
Now nobody does.
I mean, anyway, nonetheless,
college's brand,
and that's what we're
actually talking about--
- Is brand.
- Is in trouble.
- Yeah, it is, and it's
not discussed often
how top schools have a lot of value
in terms of what that degree could do,
but then the chunk of the 85% under that
is potentially just--
- My crew's shaking their
head 'cause that's been a big nuance
that I've been saying which is
if you're not going to a top 15 school,
'cause I still think the ROI is there...
- And then also what's your degree, right?
Like what are you...
If I was trying to be a doctor
I would have finished my degree in design,
does that last, do you care whether
I went to that last year?
Do you feel like this box has less value
because I'm admitting I did not finish
my last year of design school?
- You admitting you didn't finish
your last year of design school is like
one of the most important data points
of me thinking I like you.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Because I think it takes
courage and self-awareness.
Don't even get me started on people
that go to school for entrepreneurship.
- Yeah yeah yeah, I know, I know.
- I mean it's all time, it's all time,
like it's all time, it's all time.
- But that's why I went to design school,
because I recognized I
wanted to do business
but I tried to teach myself a skill
that I knew wouldn't come innately
to me which was something like designing
this product launch
stuff, but being a person
who loves business and design school
is like it's own form of torture.
- 100%.
- 'Cause you're there,
and people are presenting
work and you're like, no
one's going to buy that,
and everyone's like,
that's not why we're here.
- By the way, for fun,
that snicker from Sinan,
we met when I spoke at a
college that's entire thesis
is the entrepreneurial college in America.
- Yeah, uh oh.
- No no, there's no uh
oh, and a lot of people
would be like, "Gary,
fuck you, I went to Babson
"and it was awesome," like, cool,
Babson's amazing, and
everybody learns different,
but like really break yourself down
and ask yourself 15 years
later what was taught
in the classroom, and what wasn't?
That's all, I'm just
unemotional about this,
it's not super complicated.
- And also surround yourself...
Like, back to the why the top schools
sometimes potentially might be worth it,
think about--
- The network?
- What you want to go to school for
based on who you're going
to be surrounded by.
- Of course, or, or go work for free at 18
for the number one person in that craft.
Instead of being lucky and bumping in
to the next Jimmy Iovine, why don't you
go fucking grab Jimmy Iovine's coffee
for fucking 18 months for free?
- That's about who you
surround yourself with, again.
You can surround yourself
with great people
in a work place--
- Every single person
that wants to be in
design products right now
that's a fan of mine should email you
to work for free for you, I believe that.
- We have a great internship program,
we actually pay.
(crew laughing)
- Amazing segue way.
Actually, we got sup...
We were already jamming way too much,
I wanted to establish this.
You were entrepreneurial as a kid,
16, what was your first business?
- Selling tee shirts out
of my parents' basement.
Screen printing.
- Where did you grow up?
- Detroit.
- Love already, that's already I love.
I already love that.
- Working on classic cars.
Doing body work was my other second job.
- Really?
You're really trying to bring it here.
You're like trying to bring every,
you're like trying to fuck with our heads.
- I still drive a 72 Chevy C10 truck.
Orange, Dukes of Hazzard's orange.
(laughing)
- Go to design school,
you drop out and do what?
- Drop out and it's 2009, it's the boon
of gen one amazing products
for launching companies.
Do a Kickstarter in 2009 when Kickstarter
was four months old, raised $13,000,
realized that's exactly
how much a school term
cost at the time, realized I could make
$13,000 as opposed to spend it...
That's pretty much what went in my mind
when I dropped out, and
then I went to school
for another six months after that.
- [Gary] That makes so much sense.
- Did another Kickstarter 18 months later,
or maybe a year later, raised $250,000
and then that was a launch point
for taking that first product I had
which was a--
- Did you learn a lot
in that 18 months about crowdfunding
that made you successful--
- I mean--
- Or was it luck, or was
it serendipity, or, why?
- I learned a lot about storytelling.
So Kickstarter is like a gen one
direct to consumer marketplace, right?
It's someone going on and being like,
hey world, I've got a thing,
want to give me money for it?
Do you trust me?
Is this going to be an interaction?
- You understand communication.
- Yeah, so I realized that the reason...
From that first campaign
we had 188 backers
and the second campaign we had over 3000,
I think, if memory serves, and in between
those two periods of time I realized
that those first 188 people did not open
their wallets to us because they...
Actually, wallets was
one of the rewards...
Because they wanted a wallet from me.
They opened their wallets to us because
they were like, "This
is such a great story,
"this person in design
school with this idea."
And so 18 months later I
was even better at that,
told a really powerful story and then--
- And that's the theme of
your business now, right?
Like, even the meta of
this, when we were kind of
doing our thing, you're like,
"I want to be on the show,"
and I'm like, you know what?
Let's do it, mainly on the fact that you
were smart enough to
know the value of what
you're doing right this minute in itself
was something I wanted to reward because
it's almost like you want
to give back to the game.
Because I also understand
it, if that makes sense.
- There's a meta to this for sure,
which is like, at each
juncture in my career
it's been like how do you learn a thing
actually live the thing, build a tool
for other people to do the thing.
So I launched a product in Kickstarter,
took it to retail, sold
it all over the world,
and it was fucking painful, right?
It was hard, and rough, and
not good, in so many ways.
We didn't make money with it,
it was a success in the sense that
we shut it down intentionally,
that's sometimes what a success is.
And so we did that, but
in the course of that
we learned how to navigate the environment
of custom manufactured
packaging, how hard it was
to manage a supply chain for a business
with physical product, and we were like,
this is something we can solve for.
That was four years ago
now, and now we make
packaging for a lot of
the big e-com brands
that you know of, and the reason why
is not because--
- Like?
- Lumi's cool...
Um, Casper, FabFitFun, Parachute Home,
Allbirds, MeUndies, yeah,
companies like that.
The reason why we work with them is not
because our packaging's so cool,
actually it's really that supply chain
gets really complicated, and packaging--
- You're solving a problem.
- Packaging is different...
The plain cardboard box used to just be
something that gets something from point A
to point B, now it's going to doorsteps,
millions of doorsteps every single day.
That means the challenges
the boxes are under
are different then ever before.
The packaging world
and manufacturing world
is really grappling with
what those changes mean
and we're helping solve those problems,
but it's kind of...
I mean, I'm me, but it's kind of profound,
we're in a profound moment of how...
What packaging means to everyone,
because you couldn't even order something
like this directly to your doorstep
so relatively recently.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Yeah, it's kind of interesting.
- Knowing my audience...
How many years has this
company been around now?
- [Jesse] Four.
- What's your newest learnings in the last
six months as an
operator, as an executive,
as an entrepreneur?
You raised capital, what's
your current hot take
on raising capital?
Fun, terrible, the worst, the best?
- Current hot take on raising capital is
choose a funding model
that fits your goals.
So for me this funding
model, we're in a space
where some of our
competitors, our in status quo
competitors measure their
revenue in the Bs, as I say.
It's like a big space,
so in that kind of space,
you can raise capital
and it can be a healthy
relationship with that capital.
In my first business it
was an arts and crafts
supply that I invented in a basement.
The largest year in that business
was low seven figure revenue.
If I had raised capital in that business,
big mistake.
So fit your funding
goal, your funding method
to your goals, personally,
and your business's goals.
- Aka, venture capital
isn't the only route
to fund the business.
- [Jesse] 100%.
- But that is the current thought process
of every young entrepreneur.
- I completely unsubscribe, I feel like
that's total bull, as
someone who's doing it
I think that's totally not the case.
You--
- But you agree with me,
that it's like crazy
that every single person
thinks that's the option.
- It is completely insane, because it--
- It blows my face off.
- It blows your face off?
- Yeah, it just makes me sad, like,
people don't even know
how to build a business,
all they care about is figuring out
how to raise capital--
- I know.
- From venture capital.
- The thing is that you...
What I love--
- In the same way,
I apologize, in the
same way that everybody
in our parent's generation only thought
you could start a
company by getting a loan
from the bank.
- Getting a loan from the bank.
You can still get loans
from banks, by the way.
- I heard.
- I've very successfully gotten loans
and funded businesses that way.
I've done factoring POs, you can go
get a big PO from a retailer, factor it,
put six figures in your bank account--
- By the way, that's, I mean VaynerMedia,
this company, this company, was started
because I hustled an
$80,000 deal from Gillette
to do something which
allowed me to hire Marcus
and Zhang and Sam Taggart and we started
the company out of Buddy
Media's conference room
so I didn't have to pay any rent,
and then sit for six
months, and then our first
full year was in Sunshine Suites,
a one-off precursor to
WeWork, where I bartered
my time in helping them
build that space for space.
So for the first 18 months I had no
overhead on rent for my company
because I literally started VaynerMedia,
a $200,000,000 revenue
business, with no funding.
- Yep, it's completely possible.
It's about, it's also money is a way of...
- [Gary] Take that, Travis.
- Money equates, when used properly,
it just equates to speed, often.
So sometimes venture capital can speed
something up, or sometimes...
But it is definitely like--
- But for 97% of people it gets them
into bad behavior because any hero
can lose money each month.
- 100%, and also the thing is where do
you learn your business fundamentals,
like I think for me, I feel good
that we learned our business fundamentals.
I joke that, someone at one point,
an investor, gave me sass.
This was a few years
ago when we were having
a low runway moment, and they were like,
"You've got like four
months runway" or something,
and I was like, in my last business I had
30 days runway for four years,
I don't care, this is
not making me nervous
that I have four months revenue...
Four months runway, it's not, if you...
Cash management is king.
- God, I love you.
Cash management is king,
it's a tremendous line.
You should put a picture of your face
on Instagram with a quote around it.
- I'm going to let you do that.
(both laughing)
- So, what else do you do?
- You mean, right now at Lumi?
- I don't know, you said "I'm going to let
"you do that," so since I'm a boy
that posts photos with
quotes on Instagram,
what other interesting things do you do?
- Actually I have a YouTube show,
I call it Shipping
Things, where we just talk
about shipping things--
- You should have called it No Ship.
- Okay! (laughing)
The thing is we're so
geeky, this stuff does not
get high view count, but it is there
for the people who need it, which is if
you're starting an e-com
brand, or you're like,
"Hey, I am wondering if this product that
"I am thinking of could go to market?"
We are there to go
through all geeky details,
tell you the difference
of the different types
of tape you could use, how buying a box
might take up more space
in your fulfillment center
and cost you on storage, et cetera.
- [Travis] That show is
why we reached out to you.
- Yeah, oh yeah yeah, it's like--
- It's the story, like,
couldn't love that concept more.
Travis is in the
background saying that show
is the reason we are
even working together.
Content is the gateway drug to business.
But more importantly, you're
bringing value to your point.
98% of my audience right now listening
isn't going to watch that show,
but for the 2% that are
starting or thinking--
- [Jesse] If you need it.
- They're going to be
pumped, like that's what
you're pumped about, you're pumped to know
how to not pick the wrong tape.
- I also think--
- I'm pumped to figure out
how you and Travy are going to make sure
more of our wine doesn't
continue to break, Troudy.
I don't like our percentages on breakage,
so our 2.0--
- We're going to work on that.
- Version of this box better be real.
That's the show I want to watch.
- You can watch that show--
- I will.
- We'll post that.
But the thing that's interesting is
people give me sass about being--
- I love that you sass.
- Sass.
- Keep going.
- I feel like I've been sassed about
being the person who's
out there making boxes
into content, like I talk about this stuff
so seriously, I'm like,
do you know the types--
- Really quick, really quick.
Why do they give you
sass, what do they say?
- [Jesse] They're just like,
this is, I think that--
- Who are these losing players that judge
who haven't actually
executed in their lives?
- [Jesse] People misjudge me about how--
- Like your cousin?
- I make my life--
- Is it your cousin Karen?
(Jesse laughing)
- Do people in business too,
like other entrepreneurs
who are like working with
future of AI or something
are like, "How's your box company?"
- Oh, those dick faces?
Yeah, I love those guys.
- Yeah, and it's like, I am out there
putting out content about
something so specific
and we're so passionate about this group--
- Can you do me a favor?
When AJ and I started VaynerMedia
all our friends started
well-funded, consumer apps.
- How they doing?
- They're all out of business.
And so, you know, when
they were worth millions
on paper and changing the world,
there's nothing more gratifying
then when you're actually
building a business
on business fundamentals, managing cash,
building something real.
There's nothing more fun than having
the conversation when
you just decide for fun
to razz or sass the fuck out of them
eight years later when they're working
at some other company.
That's what's going to
happen to all these...
AI's gonna win, but 1% of the people
that are sassing you are
going to be the winners,
which means 99% of them
that are being dicks
right now need to be
held accountable, by us.
We're going to call them in four years.
I want their names.
- That's hilarious,
and there's a hilarious
stat that I think you
would get a kick out of.
We went through Y Combinator and I think
it was a fascinating life experience.
Talking about speed of learning,
and back to the school
thing for a hot sec,
when you think about
ways to learn information
Y Combinator is three months of your life
and I think that you
get a jolt to the system
that some people might spend three, four,
or five years in school
for, so I think that
when you think about
time there's something
interesting there, but
the stat that I think
you're going to get a kick out of
is that I have 1200 active YC companies,
less than 100 have 50 employees or more.
That would put Lumi in
that less than 100 bucket,
but does that...
Not that employee count
is a measure of success,
but it does kind of speak to scale,
and it is kind of
fascinating, there's so many
companies live from that program
and so few scaling, and, you know...
- Hey look, listen, and you remember
our first kind of, why we're sitting here,
when we were on that
FaceTime or what have you
that was the first time
in a very long time
that I was like, I want
to invest in this company
because that woman knows what
the fuck she's talking about.
I mean that.
- We strive for that.
- No, honestly, like, I don't
know what else to tell you.
Anybody who's listening to this podcast
right now, let's get one
phone number in for sure.
Facebook, Instagram, put
your phone numbers in
and let's definitely get a question in.
I'm unbelievably impressed with the utter
practicality and operations
DNA that you possess
in now my second conversation with you.
I mean it, I am completely blindly a buyer
of your ability to build businesses.
Blindly.
- [Jesse] I appreciate that.
- And I say that never.
- Yeah, I appreciate that.
I think a decade of just
doing it kind of helps.
- Right, 'cause it's better to do it
than go to class for it.
(Jesse laughing)
Right?
Are you dialing, Darren?
Or do they not teach that in Babson?
- [Jesse] Oh my gosh! (laughing)
- I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
You didn't dial, by the way.
- That's what I call sass,
this is what they call sass.
- That's what sass is, right?
Yeah, I call it razz,
actually, which is amazing.
- I like razz.
- Same shit.
- I could recycle that.
- Yeah, could you start
using razz a little bit?
Let's build that brand.
- Can you start using
razz and credit me back?
- I remember once I registered radool.com,
because I was going to make rad plus cool,
radool, a cultural word,
and then flip the URL.
This is a real thing I
once worked on for an hour.
(crew laughing)
Remember?
It was Vermont?
I still believe that I can make a word
go completely mainstream and will try
to do it at one point in my life.
Just completely left
field, registered the URL,
get all the handles,
and make it the new lit.
- I completely believe in that.
I completely believe in
word creation, basically.
- Somebody made up lit.
- Yeah yeah yeah, someone
made up a lot of things.
- You got it brother, really proud of you.
- [Walter] Hello?
- Walter, it's Gary Vaynerchuk and you're
in the Ask Gary Vee Show.
- [Walter] Yo, I'm going
to literally shit myself--
(all laughing loudly)
- That's an amazing way to start this.
Jess, say hello.
- Hello.
- Please say hello
to Jess.
- Please don't do that,
we can't see you, but
please don't do that.
How are you?
- Walter, I prefer you do do that.
(Jesse laughing)
- [Walter] I mean, bro,
if it's gonna bring you
a lot better content, then...
(all laughing)
- Thanks for calling, bro.
Where are you from, what are you about?
- [Walter] I'm from little Rhode Island,
I'm 27, I'm a product of
the college dropout life
because I truly found my passion,
and so I started to create
a whole bunch of clothing
and so I kind of took
a little bit of a turn
because it was becoming
more of a money thing
as opposed to the overall
growth and passion
of something I loved
to do, and so I started
to look at everything
from the numbers side,
as opposed to, you know,
in the better interest
of the actual brand.
Now I'm trying to essentially
start over with my brand.
The biggest thing that I have for you guys
would be how do you start over?
- Easily.
- Early and often.
- Yeah, easily, bro.
By recognizing it's the
easiest thing in the world
if you're able to not take
other people's judgment,
and if you're willing to
be humble and patient.
- 100%.
I shutdown one company that I ran for four
and a half years and I felt like it was...
It felt internally like it might be
this really dramatic
thing, and then you realize
that the world is so
busy and agnostic to what
you're up to, no one cares.
- Nobody gives a fuck
about you.
- But that's good news,
it's liberating, just go
forward, just figure it out.
- Listen, I with all my powers.
Nobody gives a fuck.
- Right right right, it's like,
it's so liberating when
you really wake up to that,
that you--
- How about...
Sorry, go ahead.
- No no, when you wake up to the fact that
no one really cares that much about
what you've been doing, it's kind of like,
oh, a slight bummer, and then you're like,
wait a sec, I can do whatever I want.
- Nobody cared about
your big fucking pimple
in the middle of your
head in eighth grade,
but you thought they did, but they had
their own fucking problems.
Success, or notoriety, or pressure,
is predicated on how long
somebody will give a fuck.
When Prince dies we give a fuck,
for a day.
- [Walter] Right.
- Where's all my homies
now about my man Nipsey?
We'll give them love that week,
but like, people move on with their lives.
That's just the way it is, and those were
special people, Nipsey,
Prince, like special,
1% of 1%, for the rest
of us, what do you think?
And no matter how much your ambitions
are to be special like me,
what you equally realize
is nobody gives a fuck.
How do you start over?
Easily.
Nobody gives a fuck, what
are your alternatives?
What else you gonna fucking do, bro?
- Tomorrow's a new day, and the stress
is internal for you, it's less about...
The world is ready for
your next idea, you know?
- And are you asking, theoretical,
the way we took it, or
are you asking physical?
Like, register...
What are you like...
I assume it's mental and macro, right?
- [Walter] It's 100% macro,
just for a little bit
of more context guys.
So I grew the company literally straight
from college and I took it to six figures
in a little bit over six months--
- Go ahead.
- [Walter] And that was strictly
from Instagram because--
- Of course.
- [Walter] I was actually using that back
in 2013 when it started
to really take off,
so it wasn't tradition
for brand at that point,
and so I leveraged that
and to be completely
transparent with you guys it got caught up
and crazy to me because
I'd used like 10k followers
as a shit ton, right?
And it just completely threw
my mindset out of whack.
- You got high on your own supply
- You have to realize--
- Exactly.
- [Gary] I get it.
- It's tough, the thing
is that what got you here
won't get you there kind of thinking
was just, whatever you
did on your last business
that worked, probably won't work again
in the same way, so just unhook from that
and think about what you want to do next.
- Bro, this happens all
the time, using data points
from here, I have so much empathy.
I'm so pumped that you're
so self-aware, though.
You're 27 and you understand that
that's what happened?
Bro, you know how many people get into
Y Combinator, which is in Silicon Valley
where fucking Harvard, Stanford,
all of that, in startup land,
and think they've made it?
I'm sure you had classmates in your class,
they thought they made
it when they got into YC.
- [Jesse] That's right.
- They haven't even started.
You know how many people
celebrate fundraising?
Hey, we raised three million bucks!
Party, boats, cool...
Like, dude, I get it dude, and 10k in 2013
was like, 'cause I was there, 10k in 2013
was like having three million right now.
Dude, when I had four thousand followers
on Twitter in 2007 and
went to South by Southwest,
you would've fucking thought I was Drake.
- Yeah, but everything has a moment--
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
- So the point is everything has a moment
and you see entrepreneurs sometimes
try and recreate an old moment, and it--
- So true.
- Gets super awkward,
and weird, so just think
about that, think about
how you can't recreate
that old moment where you were.
- You don't go back to high
school as a college kid
to pick up high school
chicks, okay, Walter?
- Just also don't do that.
- [Walter] No, I won't.
- Walter honestly, very seriously bro,
this is a piece of cake.
Nobody gives a fuck, and you shouldn't
give a fuck about their opinions,
and you should practice that.
- And it's liberating, it's good news.
- [Walter] I appreciate it,
and if anyone's listening,
please, please, please go follow...
On Instagram.
I appreciate it guys, thank
you for your time, seriously.
- You got it, bro.
- [Jesse] You too, you too.
- You got it Walter, take care.
It's so right, obviously I like you
because we're from the
same school I can see,
from all the things you're saying,
it's like verbatim shit, like...
Yeah.
- Yeah, you internalize this stuff
'cause it's important to you, like if you
spent the last four years
working on something
day in day out it's like to kill it
or something feels impactful.
- People feel like, "Then I
would have wasted all my time."
No you wouldn't, sitting on something
that's already dead is
wasting your time forward.
- Yes, completely and
whatever period of time,
measure each period of time by how much
you learned in that period of time.
If you learned something, take
that learning and move on,
but the learning is
what you got from that.
- And macro the learning,
a learning could be
that you learn that it was fun.
Forget about the literal,
I learned how to do taxes
that year and that was
the year that I learned
how to do storytelling.
For sure.
Another learning is you were
just a fucking knucklehead
from 22 to 25 and it was just fucking fun.
- Yeah, you had fun, maybe you learned
that you like what you like.
Oh I like running a business, or I don't,
just all that learning is pretty pivotal.
- Or you learn that the
friends that you like
having fun with are not
going to be the friends
that you build the next thing with.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they want to have fun
for the rest of their lives.
- Yeah, all of that's super valid.
But whatever you take
away from that experience,
that's what you got to move
forward into the next one.
- Do you love losing?
Microlosses?
- I just feel like I'm a...
I don't want to go full blown and say
I'm a masochist but I
think that when I find
the pain in the day, or
the pain in the month,
the pain in the year,
I'm like, there it is.
I found it.
- I fucking knew it.
- Because you know what's coming.
- Do you think that...
So I'm on board with that, now I'm going
to ask you a real 301
version of this question.
- [Jesse] Okay.
- Do you think you, even
subconsciously, create it?
- I think I seek out situations
that make the pain happen.
- Me too.
- I think I seek out the situations
where I know I'm not quite ready,
and I know that the
organization isn't quite ready,
or I changed something really fast
and I know it's a hard left turn
and you're gonna get
your neck yanked on it,
and so, yeah.
- But you genuinely believe it's right.
- [Jesse] Yeah.
- I love when my executives are like,
"You can't do that."
I'm like, you don't understand,
I'm in charge, and I think it's right.
- [Jesse] Well I generally--
- I understand what's
gonna be wrong about it,
I understand everyone's gonna cry.
I know Slack's gonna blow up at Vayner
and be like, "This fucking guy."
I know what's going to
happen, but it's my job.
- Yes, it is your job, actually.
- It's my fucking job.
- It is actually your job.
So I don't know if people get that
about that role that you're in is that
that's actually your job, and people don't
want to work with your
company if you aren't able
to make those choices,
but it's part of the job
and it means the job is painful.
- The difference between a great CEO
and not one is one knows
that they're a parent,
and one thinks that they're a babysitter.
- [Jesse] Yeah yeah yeah.
- It's your job.
- [Jesse] It's your job.
- It's your fucking job.
- It's completely integral to the role,
so I think that I know that the pain
is like going to be
created, but I also think
that the other thing I know
is that life is short, right?
When you think about life--
- And long.
- It's short and long in the sense that,
if I think to myself, oh
I could do this thing now
or I could do it in a year--
- I actually think what you're saying
which is a lot of fun for me as well
is that you don't want to regret.
- [Jesse] Yeah.
- What entrepreneurs have,
and you are absolutely
a purebred entrepreneur in my opinion,
which is probably the biggest
compliment I could give you,
we're too scared to regret
not dying on our own sword.
- Yeah, yeah.
The worst thing that could happen for me
is that what I'm up to gets boring for me,
or that we didn't take enough risks
to find out where the edges really were
of the business model.
- Or you took the advice
of a non-entrepreneur--
- That's the absolute
worst thing. (laughing)
- I know it is, the absolute worst thing
for an entrepreneur, and
I'm watching some kind
of pure-ish bred
entrepreneurs over finance,
take advice from somebody
that they admire,
and then lose, and they know in their soul
they lost with somebody
else's opinion or strategy.
That would literally
break my fucking soul.
- But that's, you know, the second that
you're following someone's advice
so that you know that you can at one point
say, well so and so said
to do blah and blah--
- [Gary] Correct.
- Is actually the moment
that you just fucked
your company--
- Correct.
The moment you realize that you
are 100% accountable for everything...
I genuinely believe, and for real,
that absolutely everything
in this company is my fault.
- Yep, yep, and so, that's
where the pain lies,
but that's also where the liberation lies.
- 100%.
- Because it's painful.
And sometimes it's like
actually, feels painful,
but then at the same time,
when you realize that,
then there's like a calm that's like,
oh, that means it's my job to make
these choices, and so XYZ.
- You're amazing, we're
going to Instagram TV,
well Instagram Live, excuse me,
to unbox this empathywines.com.
Give the website, give your show,
let's do some right hooks
here and then we'll phase off.
- All right, you can find us at lumi.com.
- L-U-M-I
- L-U-M-I dot com.
And we have a podcast called Well Made
where we interview a lot of entrepreneurs
who do direct to consumer.
And then I have a show on YouTube
at LUMIHQ called Shipping Things.
- Or soon to be rebranded to no shit.
- Not soon to be rebranded. (laughing)
- Okay, sorry, where do you put...
So listen, I actually think
you can bring a lot of value
as a CEO and entrepreneur to my audience
because I am picking up
what you're putting down,
which is very rare for me.
Do you talk about...
Where are you doing what
we just did, if anywhere?
LinkedIn, anywhere yet or are you kinda
not doing that part yet?
- Not officially as part of my brand,
I just bring candor to like,
wherever I'm at at that moment,
but so I do quite a bit of things.
- It's funny how you use the word candor,
it really is fucking candor.
- Yeah, it's just kind of like,
I don't know how to be another...
I joke that I say when
I'm really onto someone
and they're really taken aback
is that I have got one mode
and they're experiencing
it and it's just this.
(laughing)
- You know, it's so
funny, people ask me a lot
of different things about
where you're going with this,
and I'm like, I'm just not
capable of not being myself.
I'm just not, I don't have it.
- I don't have another
mode, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a weird thing to try to explain,
where someone's like, "But
why are you like that?"
And you're like, ah, this
is the way that it is.
- I don't know, why do
you flake here John?
Like I don't flake, I
love when people are like,
"Why are you like that?"
I don't know, you know?
Why are you a boy?
(laughing)
No really, like, Johnny,
why are you a boy?
When people ask things
about personalities,
it's like laughable.
- Mm hmm, it's so
integral to just your DNA.
I also, I don't know, I feel
like you use this as well,
I feel that humor is a very underutilized
skillset in business.
I love being with someone and
just sharing real information,
but making it kind of
funny and in that way.
- I cannot believe you just said that.
Literally yesterday,
somebody that works at Vayner
said to me, why don't you do
more humor on your content?
You're so funny, but none of
your content really shows that
and the only time you even remotely...
Only your vlog shows it,
but even the editors,
why are they not editing more of that in?
And I'm like, you're right.
DRock, you're fired.
(laughing)
- But it's like, I think it's
an underutilized skillset
because humor is a way of also--
- Taking tension out of the system.
- Yeah, taking tension
out, I use it to deliver
frank information faster as opposed
to skirting around issues.
- Correct.
- It's just a great tool.
- It's funny, I just realized something.
It's one of the reasons my
razz, like a lot of times...
One thing I've learned, actually
I've learned it at Empathy
and to John and Nate's
credit, as my partners,
as my younger brothers
'cause I've been with them
for a decade, it's funny,
I use humor for that.
The bad version historically
for me was razzing
to get some of my own
resentment or difficult out
and fine, because people
would like that better
than just being completely called down,
be like you fuckin' suck.
But if you do it too
much, the 37 little razzes
versus one radical conversation is worse
and I genuinely, genuinely
learned that, genuinely during,
ironic, it's very meta, during
Empathy Wines, this venture.
- [Jesse] Yeah, during this project.
- Nate and John did a very
good job communicating to me
of like, hey, 'cause razzing
is how I wanna say it.
It goes into being
condescending and other places.
When you know somebody super well,
they can take it with
love and I won't razz...
It's funny, you can always tell
how our relationship's
building on how much...
Sinan, literally today
can walk out of here
realizing we're closer than
ever because of the way
I'm razzing him on Babson,
but I wouldn't do that
to John yet, but I feel it's emerging.
I gave him a compliment on
here, but I razzed Sinan.
- [Jesse] It's gonna go from
compliment to something else.
- But it's funny, it's funny, it actually,
like if you're watching
from home, it's like,
oh he likes John, he
doesn't like that Sinan.
It's actually the reverse,
I actually like Sinan better than John.
No, no, it's actually true.
- So I'm curious about
your opinion on something.
- It's interesting.
More than me bro, it's about to go.
I'm gonna have to shave it
soon, it's gonna be amazing.
- So, there's like something
that I feel is also interesting
like, we joked about this
when I was coming in here.
I'm five feet tall, someone
said I looked younger
than I look online.
- It's Sinan guys, you should've seen it.
- Super inappropriate--
- He was like--
- Completely missed the mark--
- "You look younger than
"you do online," and I was like, thanks?
- I think it was a compliment,
but it was super not,
and it was fucked up.
- It was weird--
- I was like, damn, I got
to talk to him about that.
- So like apparently when
you meet me in person,
no matter how you're seeing me now,
I look like a teenager
and I'm five feet tall,
even though I am 31.
So the thing is, in
business that's not always
the bestest, you know?
Like, for getting--
- It's not the bestest when you're at
the mercy of the old establishment,
it's the bestest when you're not.
- Right, so humor though is actually
my way of disarming people with that too,
where like someone is like, "Whoa, whoa,
"this five foot tall girl person
"is being real serious
with me about business
"right now, but she's making it funny,
"I don't know how to feel."
I don't, you know, it's like a...
You kind of can disarm someone's pre--
- Normal.
- [Jesse] Conceived, yeah,
what their normal is.
- I think, and it's
funny, yesterday I was in
a meeting with a lot of
leaders in a department
and the way I disarm people
is actually by proving
to them even though
I'm a CEO of 900 people
that I actually know
what the hell's going on.
There's nothing more fun to me
than going to a meeting where it's a group
of senior people who
don't interact with me
everyday and they could, first of all,
especially because of the Gary B thing,
they're not even sure if
I even run this company,
and then when I roll
in and I'm just talking
and I slip in something that like,
there's no way outside of
being in that little crew
that you would know that and I say it,
it blows their faces off.
- It blows their faces off.
- No really, it's like, I love that,
I agree with disarming
or re-changing the tune
in a room, and I do use
humor to your point,
and one of the other things I love,
just to bring value of something that
somebody may want to do,
you will change a room
very quickly when you're
the most senior person
in a company when you prove to them
that you're not confused.
No different than when your parents
when you thought you were doing something
they had no idea about--
- And they knew?
- That they make a joke about it?
This is when you're older, in like--
- They're like, "How was
that party last night?"
- Late high school, college, yeah.
They're like, yeah like, Stan,
and you're like, fuck, how'd you know
I'd been hooking up with Stan?
You know, like that kind of shit?
That's a very good move for executives
because what it does
is, A, they feel great
that you actually know
what the hell's going on.
B, they're like, oh
fuck, I might not be able
to trick this person as much as...
Like there's a lot of value going on,
the same way with humor, it's like, okay,
there's a...
Whether it's
self-deprecation, or humility,
there's all these different little things
going on in a room.
- Yep, it's about finding
your style, though.
You know, people will often
ask me like whether...
I'm a very jokey person,
I use physical comedy
a lot, like some people will--
- Like, trip people?
- [Jesse] No no, no, like
people running to my--
- Like I'm going to trip Sinan
when he walks behind me, okay, got it.
- No, like with myself, like imagine--
- Hold on, you remember tripping?
- [Jesse] Yes.
- I haven't thought
about tripping in like...
Remember people tripped each
other in like fourth grade?
- I love that.
Yeah, but the thing is, like--
- Jon, right?
Like, no, it's funny, like--
- [Jesse] Tripping--
- People used to trip.
- [Jon] I was such a little shit, yeah.
- Yeah, you were, I mean,
that makes a lot of sense.
(crew laughing)
- Tripping, pantsing, like
there's a lot of weird--
- Wait, let's talk about pantsing.
- [Jesse] Pantsing?
- Who in this room, by show of hands,
knows what pantsing is?
- I mean, who doesn't?
Who--
- Well, Sinan was in Turkey.
(Jesse laughing)
So, for anybody at home that doesn't...
How old are you?
- [Jon] 21.
- Oh, I love that pants--
- You don't know what pants--
- No, he does, which is why I asked him is
that I'm pumped that pantsing continues
because in this environment I'm not sure.
Like, there were girls in my high school
that got pantsed in the
middle of the hallway,
like on some really
politically incorrect shit.
- Pantsing was alive and well for all
of my middle school and high school,
and then um, book, what did people call it
when you do the books?
You just slap the books
out of someone's hands
like an asshole.
(Jesse laughing)
- We didn't have, we didn't have...
Okay, but--
- I didn't do that,
I'm just saying it was alive and well.
- Let me just set the stage as the old dog
in the room, when I was in high school--
- [Jesse] Oh, to get booked.
- The only thing guys
could wear were boxers,
like hardcore boxers, like no other
underwear was acceptable--
- Oh no--
- Not tighty-whities, not whatever--
- [Man] Boxer briefs.
- Boxer briefs, thank you.
Only thing acceptable was baggy boxers.
The amount of my friends...
Thank god this never happened to me.
The amount of my friends that got pantsed,
in the hallway, and both shorts and boxers
went because of the nature of it...
Like, I feel like modern day pantsing,
because of briefs and other things, was...
Everybody who got pantsed got naked.
- Yeah yeah yeah! (laughing)
- Not you see their underwear, naked.
- Oh my gosh, but so--
- I feel like female
pantsing didn't happen
that way, you would see the underwear,
where as--
- Yeah, but unfortunately
wouldn't girls be wearing--
- With dudes in 94 was--
- Like, thongs and stuff?
- Penises and balls.
Naked.
(Jesse laughing)
That's what's going down...
That's what high school...
I love these kids who are like,
there's so much bullying and tension.
I'm like, there was
fucking pantsing in 94.
- There was pantsing, yes.
But so, for a second,
back to physical comedy.
When we're all walking to my office
and be like, you know, I'm CEO,
so they'll have some big
news that's not great
like you walk in there
like blah blah blah,
and then like I'll be on the phone--
- [Gary] We're going out of business!
- I shouldn't stand up
because I have another thing,
but they'll be like, I'll be on the phone,
and I'll be like, ah, and fall down,
as though the news killed
me, and then like--
- So good.
- [Jesse] Just get up and
be like, it's fine, like--
- You're such a good leader.
- [Jesse] Yeah, because it made--
- No, I'm really proud
of you, that's really--
- It calms people.
- [Gary] Our job--
- Me falling down dead,
strangely, is calming to my team.
- The number one thing,
the number one thing
that I believe I do
for a living as the CEO
of this company is eliminate
fear of my employees.
It is the number one thing I do.
- Everyone's more productive
when they're not fearful, yes.
- Correct.
- Which is--
- When you're not thinking, you're doing.
- So, secretly he's also making
you all super productive.
Yeah.
- 100%.
But in the best way.
This is actually my macro--
- But it's healthy!
- This is my macro thought
of being a businessman.
My goal, one of my absolute top goals,
is to redefine what a successful
businessperson looks like.
Why can't you be kind?
Why can't you be empathetic?
Why can't you be such a good leader
that you spend all your time...
Like, I love how, and I know you...
I already know that you
know what you were saying,
but some people are like,
"Oh, he uses eliminating fear
"to trick them to work harder," I'm like,
are you a fucking idiot?
- [Jesse] No, no, it's not a trick,
it's authentic, it just is like real--
- What are you talking about?
But people do that, they're like,
looking for the angle.
Keep looking for the angle, dick.
(crew laughing)
- I meant it authentically,
it's basically...
The funny thing...
It reminds me of, just, weird segue way--
- Of pantsing?
- No no!
- Okay, just making sure.
- It reminds me of
sustainability in packaging
in a weird segue way where basically
when we design a supply chain efficiently
it's also greener.
There's no macro trick to it.
- 100%.
- People are like, "How are
you going to make it greener?"
It's like, we're going
to truck it less miles,
we're going to do basic stuff.
It's the same way that...
It's the same thinking which
is there's no trick to it.
- People are so lost.
Get louder.
Do me a favor?
If you can do anything for me, get louder.
- [Jesse] Okay. (laughing)
- You have absolutely the right framework
for what is needed in the business world.
- Yeah.
- Get louder.
Your practicality is...
Your mix of black and white and gray,
of teeth and heart, is
exactly the framework
of what I believe needs to be the pedestal
of executives and
entrepreneurs in the world.
- Yeah, thank you.
- You're welcome.
That's our show.
(upbeat music)